as cases start to go down covered
restrictions are loosening here in
nevada and with spring nearly here water
parks are getting ready to reopen yeah i
can't believe it bianca holmen live at
cowabunga bay in henderson with a look
at
how the park is getting ready biake
looks like you're
getting ready out there you have your
lifeguard thing i forgot
what is that thing called a lifeguard
rescue
device floaty i don't know oh daily
heidi we're here relaxing at cowboy bay
i got my
sunscreen you know protects us with the
spf
but we're here at the water park right
it's starting to warm up it's a little
chilly this morning but soon it's going
to be
hot outside and the water park is open
and you know they were open last year
right shane
so you all are used to what it's going
to take to keep guests safe and also
your staff states tell us about those
covet
protocols that you all do yeah so last
year fortunately we were
able to open around the end of may under
new covet protocols which include social
distancing
mask wearing of course not in the water
but whenever you're
in line or in the pool or coming through
the gate
there's additional sanitation going on
we temperature check all our employees
and we're operating at a limited
capacity so those are still in place
until the governor
um you know lightens the the protocols
yeah and tell us i know opening day is
coming up soon at the end of march i
can't believe it's here already
you all got a special event planned for
that day as well right yes so we're
super excited because last year we
weren't able to be open for spring break
but this year we opened march 27th for
spring break and we have a polar plunge
that will benefit
the special olympics of southern nevada
happening that day yeah that's
incredible i mean again i think people
are looking forward to getting outdoors
again
the weather is warming up it's pool
season getting ready to be here
so of course anything else you want to
tell folks out there as you all prepare
to get ready to open
tickets is that all back to normal
everything is happening online this year
as we try and reduce you know contact
points
just want to say that the cdc does say
that chlorinated water
prevents coveted spread so being in a
pool or a wave pool is a great place to
come out and have fun and still stay
safe
exactly and stay in cool and of course
coming up to make all this happen
they gotta have employees and they're
hiring hundreds of folks so we've got
details coming up on that
in the next half hour so be sure if you
stick around if you got some college
students that need some work
they can come work here we got that
coming up for you in the next half hour
back to you guys in the studio it's all
ready with her towel and sunglasses and
making us think about summer already i
know it and we're just gonna get you a
drink with an umbrella bianca you'll be
all ready to go
i'm waiting for it alex send one over
okay we'll take some in here too